Megan starts this hour in Charlotte
North Carolina
hi Megan how are you good how are you
thank you so much for taking my call
sure what's up well my husband and I
have quite a bit of that we've been
wearing our babies at number two and
we've already paid a little over twenty
two thousand this year towards our debt
but they'll have a hundred and seventy
four thousand left yeah we have a little
bit of credit card and medical a
fourteen thousand left on a car and then
the rest of it is in student loans that
my husband acquired when he was young
and dumb so what's his degree in its IT
he went out of state to a private school
for college what's what hurtled into him
we're at one hundred and thirty three
thousand a year okay all right so how
can I help um so basically on five of
the student loans are all under seven
thousand dollars so we feel pretty
confident that we can breathe through
those pretty quickly three of them were
making monthly payments on and then the
two biggest ones total eighty thousand
dollars and they're in default but they
have called to offer a settlement of
eight thousand dollars so I guess we're
trying to figure out if we should have
set to the settlement I'm sorry I'm
sorry
you owe eighty thousand dollars and they
offered to settle them for eight
thousand dollars yeah they offered to
settle for $8,000 yes these are not
Sallie Mae loans there was navien I
think you misunderstood well I sent us
the paperwork you have it in writing
that they will accept $8,000 settling
for 80 yes but I believe they will then
that's it 1099 that's not their choice
that's the law forgiving forgiving debt
is income and so you'll get 1099 Don it
I do not
I've never seen this program I didn't
know this existed I'm learning something
today if you can validate if you can
validate that this is I'm sorry if you
can validate that you can settle an
$80,000 debt for $8,000 you send them
the check today you take this deal
absolutely take this deal your 1099 on
the difference is 8 is 72 thousand
dollars of taxable income and you know
which is going to be taxed at 30 percent
so that's gonna be another 20 grand
right tax bill but I mean you just you
know counting taxes and everything you
just settle 80,000 for 30 right that's
what we're kind of looking at which
obviously we would then have to figure
out how to pay the IRS back well you got
you got till April to come up with the
20,000 sure so you put it up at the
front of your debt snowball so you move
everything up to the top you may know
you just moved the 20,000 up but you
both those at the top yeah yeah if we
can sell them if we can settle a an
$80,000 debt for $8,000 today and
$20,000 in April yes you move that to
the front of your debt snowball
absolutely okay and then I know your
answers probably no but I have the
ability to put that $8,000 on a credit
card but not know the answer is yes I
would do that all right yeah get this
deal done before they change their mind
because I've never heard of this
anything anywhere near this good I do
not understand why this is happening and
so I'm really really nervous I'm really
really nervous or some part of this you
didn't understand from what I've read
online and from what they sent me it's
like it's like because it's never had a
payment on it and it's over ten years
old they're settling for I guess like
10% of what is owed on it so you found
some evidence that this has happened
before
okay I've seen online evidence of people
having this happen
yes okay all right good well I'm again
aye-aye-aye this I learn something every
day on this show and I just learned
something today
so I'm happy for you yes because here's
the thing today you owe eighty thousand
at the end of the day you owe eight
thousand on a credit card in April
you're gonna owe an additional twenty
right that's what you're facing here
okay so these are you know we're
reducing your debt
we're not borrowing money we're moving
the debt to $8,000 on a credit card from
80,000 of them and a future problem
coming up in April of 2000 yeah
absolutely I'm doing this deal in a
heartbeat lock her down get her done